كان التحقيق يتمركز
حول مضمون خطبه الجمعه التي القيتها في
المسجد الاقصى المبارك بتاريخ 111 من هذا
الشهر وكان الحديث بانني اؤيد تبادل الاس
التبادل بين الاسرى قلت لهم دعم انا احث
على تبادل الاسرى لان التبادل الاسرى هي
عمليه انسانيه
حضاريه يشجعها الاسلام بل يحث عليها
وبالتالي نحن مع تبادل الاسرى بغض النظر
عن هويه الاسرى او تاريخ الاسرى هذا لا
يعنينا نعم يعنينا هناك اسرى لابد ان يحصل
بين فيما بينهم تبادل ثم تناول
موضوع وصيه ابو بكر الصديق رضي الله عنه
الذي نصت على تحريم قتل الاطفال
والنساء وتحريم هدم الصومعه يعني المساجد
والكنائس والكنس وكذلك تحريم قتل
الحيوانات وقطع الاشجار وهدم المنازل قلت
له
هذه اخلاق الاسلام في التعامل سواء في
حاله حرب او ح
سلم
ن